[Music]
what is your name
Scott waters just first things cool
social so okay I'm gonna ask everybody
say three question number one on a scale
of one to ten one being a leg side
you'll be free by old Michael Jackson
[Music]
so one myself ten Michael Jackson how do
you rate yourself as a day three I like
that let me tell you why I like that
because three and then he's five and
people like okay well let's don't tell
anybody that
okay so Scott is a three and now give
you one word that describes your dance
style athletic
okay so now I get to know the name of
your best dance me but who are you my
name is Brenda do you think three is an
accurate number
yeah okay
is called the shortness
what's ugly called one of my legs doing
some Jennifer and Jennifer 110 180 lanes
and me Michael Jackson make yourselves a
daze I like but say with some confidence
as good as you
what is that one word to describe
yourself your dance style one word to
describe your dance you need
did a house just land on there since
what is the name of your best dance what
is your name Stephanie alright yeah
and Stephanie you can be excited to be
under yeah okay
are you nervous okay deep breath okay so
Stephanie one through ten companies but
you are setting yourself up your mama
this is a fickle crowd then winner see
attend what's the name of your dance
topless [ __ ] right
and what what's the name of your best
dance move I call it a the fire
yeah
remember its interpretive things you do
not have to be a good dancer just feel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
music Scotty's a solid three biggest
styles
and he does whatever the [ __ ] that thing
was
don't show everybody don't thank you
Jennifer right Jennifer you are six and
in you you you do the hip your dance
styles unique might never feel the music
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
oh I can see them
I'm family
you're not I'm sorry mommy
Stephanie's at and everybody no I don't
think I want to say
just you know any singing into the
microphone
shut me you're just going to be charged
with the dancing and show you something
here we go you ready go Stephanie's ten
she's five
blind able to film interactions last I
[Music]
[Music]
the third place will go back to the seat
and in the top two I will play as much
of the song that I doubt the same they
will dance through that you guys choose
the winner
[Applause]
nobody never
[Applause]
your back wheel turns [ __ ] you
time for the hip
[Applause]
I mean that's the new big day for her
ladies gentleman a last-second addition
somebody who without her we would not
have been able to do this because I was
about to call it because it was taking
too long she ran right down bowls and
her [ __ ] hands
this here from this fire Stephanie
[Applause]
thank you so much for coming here the
way you sit up now you're curious what
you have in store for round number two I
mean because you brought the hip hop
which was a good move see little War II
general and I'm not gonna be watching
but I'm expected to hear
the high-fiving over new healthy choice
you're stealing for something that eat
that right but this is going to be a lot
of fun your dance ladies and gentlemen
let's see how much of this song America
hey buddy you
[Music]
[Music]
now I know I would be winded as I didn't
see you flick but I can see a pretty
tight ass but I thought I knew a
gentleman you came within those limits
when you knew that both of you were
running out of moves it was very nice to
you do I liked your physicality
I liked your fearlessness man is what I
like the most and so this was
[Applause]
we're is slow and sultry and make this
dude take off his [ __ ] glasses
it was like I can't see that anymore
we're two new jeans does not feel good
for anybody
okay the hint and guys again ever
what's up whatever a hundred and ten
percent
yeah if we're just going on who's a
better answer I don't really think
there's much of a question but I love
this it depends on what you're into are
you into that are you into the passion
of you
[Applause]
are you somebody there's actually plenty
cool parents the sexy woman dancing in
front to you ladies who is your work sir
what's what's what's the name not for
you so just remember what he said you
kids 100 so just make it say here we go
[Applause]
[Applause]
one time
[Music]
I know even more she leaves London to me
she goes we're gonna get that boat again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you